[Musique]
18 juillet
c'est l'espagne de 1936
[Musique]
une moitié de l'espagne moeurs de la
main de l'autre
[Musique]
près de six cent mille personnes hommes
femmes et enfants passent la frontière
française
[Musique]
trop
à la casse on
parfait amour
non
mon sens trop souvent ce qu'ils sont
installer deux points d'eau
aia
comment
ça veut dire nous sommes qui nous sommes
von ah on est fatigué d'entendre
toujours toujours la même chose de
toujours d'être tourné vers le passé on
a on connaît le passé on n'a pas besoin
de l'évoquer il est déjà dans notre sens
dans notre dans nos attitudes dans tout
le nous vers l'avenir et faisons quelque
chose ensemble et les morts ils sont
morts et on sait qu'ils sont morts mais
c'est pas parce qu'on pense tout le
temps aux morts et que qu'on leur a un
service finalement la meilleur service
qu'on peut le rendre c'est de faire ce
qu'ils ont ils auraient voulu faire
c'est ça le montmagny et les plis de la
défroque
les vignes est con comme ça il est pris
avec ses costumes c'est tout tout tout
tout tout laisser bloquer tout parce que
les fassis et son entrée de gamme
appelée
il est un peu compte pas de
concentration à dix jours mais
il va se marrer n'est jamais retourné en
espagne jamais même pas voulu même pas
voulu j'amène mon mari attendait rien
des francos ouh là là non
moby ici ça laisse appris qu'il était
mort de mon mari je vais décider des
faits passés pop il soutiendrait à voir
ma famille parce que j'ai tout d'un coup
je suis resté sans voix
londres may famille 14 ans un espagnol
très soudés entre eux il a très mal
d'alcool vous savez là bas on regarde
comment comores à la barre ont perdu
personne à la barre alors je suis
intérieur la famille ma famille ira bien
des plus tôt deux femmes qu'aucune autre
chose et comme ça la vie
vous aimeriez revivre en espagne
aujourd'hui vous aimeriez nous mais
parle pas moi ou
ni pour la mentalité ce qu'ils sont
son seul rôle est très important encore
sonne comme je suis dit ça fait 40 ans
encore on lève la main l'idée est un
hymne aux normands et bijoux holloway
bijoux ça suffit pour moi je ne pouvais
pas plus moi à la base pour chez moi
sous le taux nous on parle pas en
espagne bien que la religion
b2 pour l'automne je le disais à ma
famille que je n'avais pas fait ce que
je devais l'autre mon avis faut penser
maintenant toute l'année pour manger il
faut prier
les soirs il faut crier pour toutes à
niveau puis
sarko va rentrer lui en espagne si
l'accord entre mes copains je ne sais
pas si simple ludique et à combattre et
on verra
mais pas que l'appétit dont le revenu
est là doivent être trois à
supporter quand je veux pas savoir
combien le portait mieux ça ne vous
inquiète pas qu'il aille en espagne
s'est pas privée pamir et un grain de
choses à la baille là bas
il se fait des illusions quand ils
pensent à lesparre espagne il sera de
s'occuper à laval on le voit la
mentalité espagnole contre le nouveau
c'est différent
bagot
suit
espérons
passer ses idées
oui je trouvais dans un milieu de
réfugiés presque tous deux réfugiés et
que le sujet et qui se révèle toujours
c'était l'heure c'était la guerre
c'était le fait cette situation d'être
réfugié d'être à l'étranger d'être
d'être un étranger finalement chaque
année c'était là c'était le retour
c'était toujours là on voyait le retour
toujours à l'année prochaine le retour
en espagne c'était l'année prochaine
dans le passé ça va changer ça m'a
changé et est un d'année en année on
compte arena le reste est quand même 25
ans dans le premier mois
au début je jouais de la guitare et le
mans comme ce que les autres m'avaient
appris de ces princesses qui m'a fait
aimer
la chanson par elle même attends je
pensais qu'une chanson c'était quelque
chose de plus frivole c'est une chose qu
elle passe temps une chose de léger et
avec brassens je me suis rendu compte
que tu as à travers la chanson on peut
faire une oeuvre de valeur et même une
oeuvre universelle qui
qui va plus loin que la circonstance et
qui le temps ne nous aura pas donc c'est
une valeur réelle
et j'ai l'impression qu'avec la chanson
je touche les gens et je n'ai pas le
temps je participe avec eux
on va tous j'ai l'impression que je les
appelle à aller ensemble vers un but
vers quelque chose de la joie des
classiques
l'impression d'être un objet
d'admiration
une chose qu'on écoute on trouve très
bien et qu'après on oublie mais que ça
n'a aucune conséquence directe sur la
marche d'un pays ou sur la marche des
gens ce
pas ce moment en tout cas vous chanter
des chansons oui comment est ce que vous
en faites ces chansons voulait composer
quel est votre inspiration général je
m'inspire des poètes espagnols de poètes
classiques et contemporains des poètes
qui traitent de sujets et les problèmes
qu'ils
regardent le peuple espagnol alors moi
je deviens à travers le jeu devient de
leurs porte-voix et pourquoi est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous éprouvé l'envié et
le besoin de ton esprit parce que
fondamentalement l'espagnol et si j'ai
quelque chose à dire si j'ai quelque
chose à apporter dans un endroit du
monde c'est en espagne alors je trouve
que ma place et en espagne parce que
paris espère toujours activité c'est
très bien ça va tomber dessus
et cinq taupes et et des intellectuels
ne pas toucher vraiment le peuple s'est
fait d'illusions et centres actuels
serena en hauteur et en externe a réduit
allez vous conscient de tout ça il faut
que
financier il faut le savoir l'espagne
aujourd'hui c'est une
vie complète
vous allez respect quand vous voulez
mais il était souvent napoli il vit à
paris pour respirer tout ce qui ne tue
pas respirer d'espagne c'est
contraignant la pensée des inconnus
c'est dur c'est un homme il dit c'est
vrai il ne fait pas respirer et on
arrive à l'avant un moment qu'on souffre
mais c'est quoi et ça que c'est vrai
c'est différent avec problèmes tels
comme aux batteries la peau c'est
antonio
un final plein tout ça que l'espagne
donne pas ce qu'il a vécu et l'ami d'un
conte tradition parce qu' elle ne peut
pas s'exprimer librement mais les
questions de paco ce qui n'est pas
pleine mais des sources d'inspiration
que l'espagne dans alors il montre là et
je ne crois pas qu'il sera réceptionné
c'est pas parce que tu es il lui ils
éventrent poule pour être là bas un
nombre de vedettes il rentre à mon avis
pour ses racines ses racines disputation
les 21 ans cette époque que même dans
dans cet étouffement les peuples il a
quelque chose en vue a donné par des
artistes comme une intuition seulement
c'est ce que j'ai fait par exemple d'une
musique / sur un thème qui de grenade
par exemple le voir arabe qui a perdu
deux dernières règne qui était tenue par
les arabes et je fais une musique sur ce
thème là et on m'a dit que on dirait que
je suis en train de par la musique de de
faire voir de montrer l'alhambra et
enfin une grenade et j'ai jamais été à
grenade pourtant
[Musique]
une
non
alors
passez tous les hommes libres
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
le 2
tout aussi l'audace et de la respiration
à nos récents sur la souris luna l'eau
et ça ne semblait presque enjouée son
allez
[Musique]
là
pour tous ceux-là
[Musique]
paris pour moi c'était un tout c'était
plein de vie c'était le ville de combat
y est plein de fer versailles je me suis
intégré à un groupe de théâtre espagnol
de la cara gars qui étaient là on s'est
dit qu'il y avait beaucoup d'espagnols
de migrer y faisait une vitre isolés ici
alors on a voulu leur donner un peu de
vie culturelle et comme ça je me veux
m'intégrer avec la ce public que que je
ne touche pas parce que je ne suis pas
je ne suis pas en espagne et on s'est
rendu compte que
à l'intérieur de l'espagne comme ici il
y avait d'autres gens là bas aussi qui
travaillait dans le même but que nous
vraiment par exemple je crois que c'est
celui qui chante tout ce que ce que des
milliers de gens pensent tout bas vous
pensez que son retour va être
intéressant enfin que c'est important
que je rentre en espagne et moi je crois
que c'est absolument indispensable
grande entre l espagne c'est à dire et
je crois que sa place là bas surtout
sans oublier que la place de quelqu'un
qui fait que me dire un tcc toujours et
où les parts du monde mais il faut
sarrasine et si je peux dire
à paris l'absent racines oui je vois
qu'à paris et on a le temps gère des
citrouilles et un peu dans une société
trop cosmopolite qui arrivent jusqu'à
nous cacher le progrès elle convient je
suis pas le cas concret des propos mais
je crois que c'est une situation assez
difficile
voilà c'est ça c'est que ce que je pense
par exemple à paris le mois je veux je
veux donner quelque chose à paris et
quel public qui lie à paris ce qui
laisse un public il ya un peu de tout et
à quoi ils s'attendent quand on présente
quelqu'un et qui sont en espagnol gil
satan doit à l'idée qu'ils ont de
l'espagne réalisé qu'on en a fait d'eux
les années les années et comme moi je ne
correspondent pas à ceux qui s'attendent
ils sont dessus et moi aussi je suis
dessus et est d'autant plus je me trouve
de plus en plus isolé est d'autant plus
il faut que je cherchais mon public mon
public c'est l'espagne se trouve en
espagne c'est paco la première chanson
vous allez qu'on pousse et je crois que
votre enfin vous avez pris l'aspiration
dans un livre oui les trois sur la lame
dalhausser
et toi moi je crois que votre expérience
est beaucoup plus direct et plus besoin
de livres bon on a vu le livre mais au
moment des chartes et moi je passais pas
jamais un chanteur c'est à dire
je venais de xativa lance dans une moto
est ce que le vent c'était la guitare
c'était ce qu'on passait la flamme et sa
soeur de six ans viennent souvent et
c'était comme ça après on l'achète et
jamie moyer passait pas jamais des
chiens terre sa venue un peu tout
quels sont les problèmes concrets qui se
posent à vous fait ce que vous pouvez me
raconter des anecdotes de choses
pouvaient encore la grèce est ce qu'il
ya tout un processus
pour repêcher un terrain public enchaîne
pas un public comme ici à
l'improvisation il faudra incarner il
faut faire l'examen pour avoir ses
carnets en examen oui et chaque fois
qu'on chante il faut passer les plus
grands palaces assure alors tu fais pas
toujours
les programmes que tu as pensé alors il
faut saragih reçues ce grâce à sur
désigne un après des chansons que tu as
enregistré un disque ça va ça money back
to le prochain terrain public j'entends
que des chansons que tu chantes un
public s'est vendu pas que tu te
pourrait enregistrer un disque et des
chansons qui sont enregistrés en
discutent échangent un public ne tenait
pas c'est pas la radio c'est à dire que
tout ça se fait ce sont différents et ça
n'a rien à voir avec la télévision parce
que la télévision d'apple on t'appelle
pas à dire que la télévision la radio
sont des moyens différents après il ya
là la chose de tous leurs sites en
direct est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la jeunesse veut d'autre
chose que vous les séparant
bon ben ça c'est un problème assez
longue son surgissement été ramené de
d'une façon de plaire je bouaké
dans le cas de l'espagne et tous ces
gens qui sont nés après 1939 il y en a
certaines coupures que c'est pas si
forte qu'on me l'a prononcée mais ce
qu'il est mais qu'il y est c'est à dire
que nous n'avons pas la vive ans de la
verser ville nous nous voyons surtout
les foetus est ce qu'on peut faire c'est
pas ce qu'on a fait ça me pousse à
oublier c'est ce qu'on a fait est ce que
voudrait que les espagnols extérieur
pense un peu trop à se passer enfin que
de ça c'est pas
vraiment c'est difficile parce que tout
le monde trouve deux émigrés qui sont
beaucoup plus au jour que des jeunes qui
habitent là bas des dents et on trouve
des immigrés qui sont absolument
s'arrêter 1936 1939 mais on retrouve des
délais de tout façon est une chose c'est
toujours sûr que l'aspect riaz vive vie
vendée et éclatement de violence la plus
rance cricket est là en civil ça laisse
surtout à la personnalité de l'individu
les 130 journaux et ça ce n'est pas
l'expérience vivant individuelle
personnelle ce qui nous différencie mais
nous parlons de cet angle là d'une façon
presque
d'historique ce que nous n'avons pas
vécu et ses émigrés qui jaillit des
poutrains de même une part d'une façon
encore ce sens en son souvenir c'est sa
force vous pouvez beaucoup d'eux était
le sens de sa vie un
élu manière objective est ce que vous
vous trouvez que la société espagnole
enfin en train d'évoluer de changer ce
que même le gouvernement a fallu est ce
qu'il ya une démocratisation comme
martin est ce que cette amnistie un sens
enfin s'éteignent dolto moi je préfère
ne pas parler d'eux j'habite là bas je
préfère ne pas parler de ce nom quelque
chose c'est à dire je peux parler de
société tel que je le connais il ya une
évolution très clair à dans les domaines
de l'institutionnalisation jeu s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé après le
référendum le jusqu'à maintenant c'est
de la misssion
et un changement surtout de sociétés
surtout de vie réelle mais pas
d'institution lien décalage entre ce que
la vie réelle et c'est ce que sont les
institutions et ça se voit que ça
produit ces déséquilibres qui ont qu un
simple de dire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
by ap
d'un temps que sera notre d'un pays qui
reste à faire le chante l'espérance et
pleure le peu de fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya
paris
m
[Musique]
loin des souvenirs inutile et des
vieilles passions nous ne suivrons pas
les anciens hambourg
et nous pendant
[Musique]
nathan qui est déjà un peu notre de ce
pays que nous faisons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
diana c'est la personnalité santé mas et
marty taille ce cinéma saccadé raconté m
eramet est un
film à faire
parce que nous sommes au fond du gouffre
sans même pouvoir dire que nous sommes
qui nous sommes
je voudrais vous donner vie provoquer
des actes nouveau ce qu'il nous faut ce
sont des cris dans le ciel et sur terre
des sacs
boa ci apparaît le pauvre et pourrait si
en effet ça n'y a qu'au moment de
grandir
comme à laquelle ces crimes au stress
avec l'espoir minhotos
paracétamol
[Musique]
le trois quarts aile
celle-ci pékin en avant est à mon stock
alpha
est au camp nou
mardi elle apprécie accord servira comme
laurent courtois
quel aveu
mano solo se tenir avant mardi de
l'accord et si longtemps ma partie
ce qu'il nous faut ce n'est pas une
poésie pensée goutte à goutte ce n'est
pas un bon produit ce sont des cris dans
le ciel et sur terre d acre
[Musique]
l'espace personnel mais ça ne m'étonne
mais sienne dans les autres agnel en
aveugle
caracol autre espagnol
la españa sau ça fait
well soon apprécié avatar on appelle ça
notre sommeil affronte anna souffrant
d'un mal fait
bien l'as monaco
pour kevin bacon
que seulement
strauss kahn
[Musique]